Rotten Tomatoes aggregates movie reviews
and uses them to give every movie a
percentage rating indicating they're
agreed on quality but just because
something has a low rating on Rotten
Tomatoes doesn't mean you shouldn't
watch it this is especially true for
genres like science fiction which tend
to get reviewed especially harshly so
we've put together a list of sci-fi
movies that are rated quite low on
Rotten Tomatoes but are still worth
watching some of them are good but
misunderstood and some of them are bad
but interesting either way don't let the
critics dissuade you from giving these
movies a look Speed Racer
you've probably heard plenty of
Defense's of the Wachowski siblings
speed racer by now a bomb upon its 2008
release it's since become a beloved cult
classic based on the American
localization of a Japanese anime the
movie rejected realism in favor of
oversaturated futuristic visuals and
characters with looks and names right
out of the car too
but to the surprise of many there's no
parody or cynicism in speed racer' the
characters are played as real people
with emotions and believable motivations
and speed racer' in particular is very
sincere young man who just wants to be
the best at the only thing he's good at
the racing scenes are a delightful mix
of speed color and editing Speed Racer
isn't just a weird movie worth watching
it's a genuinely great film that the
public just failed to appreciate upon
its release Last Action Hero Arnold
Schwarzenegger was a megastar in 1993
and Last Action Hero was intended to be
a huge summer blockbuster but it became
a legendary flaw critics hated it and
audiences just didn't have time for it
what's interesting about Last Action
Hero is ultimately what makes it a
failure it's a parody of over-the-top
action films that allows itself to
become and over-the-top action film it
satirizes overuse tropes and then turns
around and uses them with barely a wink
Schwarzenegger plays Jack Slater the
hero of a series of action films who
finds his way into the real world but
also turns up as himself in the real
world scenes I'll be back to say that
video that's what you always say it
doesn't all quite hold together but it's
still entertaining and some excellent
performances along with the grand scale
of what it's trying to do narrative Lee
make it an interesting watch Jupiter
ascending Jupiter ascending is the
second with shouse key film on the list
and it won't be at all surprising if it
becomes as much of a cult classic as
speed racer wants a little more time as
fast the major flaw of Jupiter ascending
is that it tries to do too much Mila
Kunis stars as Jupiter Jones a poor girl
from Earth who finds out she's next in
line for a vast inheritance from outer
space Channing Tatum plays a wolf man
from space who's assigned to protect her
from the mini forces aligned against her
chief among those forces is Eddie
Redmayne who plays an evil alien who's
human and appearance but unmistakably
reptilian and demeanor
there are certainly valid criticisms
about the move the plot is definitely
convoluted and some of the dialogue
isn't great but a lot of the critics
that contributed to Jupiter ascending
'slow Rotten Tomatoes score seem to have
a problem with the basics of the space
opera sub-genre it may not be a perfect
movie but time will almost certainly be
kind to it events horizon
despite its bad reviews event horizon
might be the most frightening outerspace
horror film that doesn't involve face
huggers or Xenomorphs in fact there are
no aliens in this movie at all unless
you count an unseen and shapeless evil
the event horizon was a ship equipped
with a new kind of interdimensional warp
drive which disappeared on its test
flight seven years earlier
now it's reappeared near Neptune and
another ship is sent to investigate what
the crew finds is a ghost ship that
seems to have recently returned from
Hell itself one by one they encounter
manifestations of their dreams and
nightmares most of them don't survive
this is a grisly and disturbing movie
that's definitely not for everyone but
if you like horror the haunted house in
space premise is interesting and the
scares are definitely there what do you
think you're doing Doug
they wanted to know where the ship has
been
I Masters of the Universe Masters of the
Universe is a big glorious mess adapted
from the popular line of toys it
probably earned it's low Rotten Tomatoes
rating but it's still pretty fun
especially if you're into that cannon
films VHS aesthetic Dolph Lundgren plays
Heymann the Barbarian who must defeat
Skeletor played here by Frank Langella
Skeletor
the film contains very little of the
mythology from the Masters of the
Universe cartoon comics but it tells a
pretty fun action-oriented story about
an eternal war in a sci-fi fantasy world
spilling into 1980s earth most of the
cast is quite good and Lundgren's
physical acting is perfect for the
character of he-man
even if you can't always understand what
the saying and this device of yours get
us to Grayskull secondly to the
sorceress honestly that kind of sums up
the whole movie it doesn't always make
sense but you want to keep looking at
Howard the Duck Howard the Duck is
remembered as one of the biggest bombs
of all time based on the Marvel comic by
Steve Gerber
it was intended to be an animated film
however producer George Lucas owed
Universal a big summer release so he
decided to just have a special effects
people build a duck suit and make the
film live-action the movie starts as an
off-kilter comedy and then escalates
into an action film until it climaxes
with a battle against a giant monster
unfortunately it lacks the strong
writing and cast a veteran comedians
needed to make that all work
nevertheless Howard the Duck is worth a
watch just for how weird it is don't
shed any tears over me what you can
wallow in your own self-pity right
[Music]